hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on luffy anniversary comm
thank you and enjoy
okay so first up is chylomicrons and
let's figure out what's going on with
them so they are the largest lipoprotein
they're the largest lipoprotein and they
are the least dense lipoprotein why why
are they the least dense well because
they're 85% triglycerides and
triglycerides aren't very dense entities
okay they are produced in the fed state
ok why is that well let's think about
the function okay well what is the
function the function is they deliver
dietary otherwise known as exogenous
lipids mainly triglycerides so have that
written here just hit it to make you
think okay so they deliver dietary
lipids okay so it makes sense that
they're producing the fed state and
which hormone is dominant during the fed
state insulin okay they're produced in
the fed state but where they're produced
in the intestinal test and all
epithelial cells and that should also
make sense if we think about the
function if their job is to deliver
dietary lipids these are things that we
ate when we eat our food goes down our
esophagus trusts I'll make it eventually
into our intestine where we absorb it so
it makes sense that are being absorbed
into the intestinal epithelial cells and
then from there
these chylomicrons take them and
transport them in our body and they
enter the blood one to two hours after a
meal so yeah so I mean this should make
sense and I I guess I just mentioned
that so thinking about the function
helps you understand why this stuff is
the way it is another thing is that it
accepts proteins from HDL to become
mature chylomicrons so there are these
things called Nation column migrant
nascent color by microns which can
eventually become mature chylomicrons
where does this actually happen this
happens in the blood this must happen in
the blood because that's where HDL is so
what are the main april proteins in
chylomicrons well the key one is be 48
be 48 is unique to chylomicrons there's
also C 2 and E and those come from HDL
so let's take a look at this this might
be kind of messy but just follow me
through it and we should be ok all right
so let's start up here at the top left
in the intestinal lumen the intestinal
lumen so the intestinal lumen that's
what we're going to have the digestive
products from the food that we ate
we're gonna have some fatty acids and
some two mono a so glycerols this just
means that the the acyl group that's
attached to the glycerol is on the two
carbon or the second carbon of the
glycerol backbone so these things going
to be taking up into the intestinal
epithelial cells across the brush border
from the intestinal lumen this movie are
we'll take them and synthesize
triglycerides the rough ER will make the
protein a bo b48
they go to the golgi and the goals you
will spit out this nascent chylomicron
which has triglycerides in a high
content as well as b48 as well as a few
other you know things like phospholipids
and and cholesterol and some cholesterol
esters but though in small amounts most
of it is triglycerides so from the
intestinal epithelial cells the nascent
chylomicron will travel through into the
lymph to the lymph where we have the
nascent chylomicron and it will
eventually be dumped into the blood a
blood capillary of the bloodstream okay
so this here in red here everything is
bound in red is the blood okay so this
nascent chylomicron with this b48 a pro
protein needs to mature and in order to
mature it needs
HDL to give up both it's a possi too as
well as it's a PO
to the chylomicron the color micron
picks them up and becomes a mature
chylomicron here so this is a mature
chylomicron and vhdl hops off with only
its eighth one now this mature
chylomicron has a bunch of triglycerides
in it in the blood it'll arrive to this
this enzyme called LPL otherwise known
as lipoprotein lipase okay lipoprotein
lipase with that does is it takes the
triglycerides that are in the
chylomicron it takes those fighters to
Aizen circle that in different color
let's do like pink perhaps so the
triglycerides here in the chylomicron
are going to come across and get cleaved
by the LPL into glycerol and fatty acids
and the lipoprotein lipase is anchored
on sort of on the wall of the capillary
in the bloodstream so when those
triglycerides come to it they're going
to get cleaved into glycerol and fatty
acids and these lipoprotein lipase ha's
are going to be near muscle tissue and
adipose tissue and so what happens is
that the glycerol on the fatty acids hop
off of once the struggle is broken down
and the fatty acids get taken up by the
cells in this case here to the muscle
and over here into the adipose tissue
okay now the muscle cells basically
these fatty acids break them down via
via beta oxidation loops that's not
pretty
via beta oxidation to give se toca ways
which can go to the TCA cycle and the
electron transport chain and eventually
give you ATP so the muscle basically
uses it uses the fatty acids for energy
um whereas the adipose tissue will take
the fatty acids activated fatty acyl
Koei's and can join them with glycerol
3-phosphate to make triglycerides which
will be stored right so it stores energy
now one thing I could sort of zip past a
little bit quickly there was that
lipoprotein lipase is actually activated
by c2 so that's something that was
mentioned in that that chart on the
April proteins and or April lipoproteins
in that part two video so this C 2 is
actually activating LPL in fact since
we're in the Fed State another thing
actually activates this LPL and that is
insulin so insulins gonna have to be
this LPL it activates both this one and
this one I just drew both of them to
kind of show you that there would be
some near the muscle insulin to the
adipose tissue so now the triglycerides
that were cut into the fatty acids or
the fatty acids and the glycerol we know
what happens to the fatty acids they're
taken up by this issue's the glycerol
that's going to end up being recycled by
it's gonna be sent back to the liver
okay so we can see that the arrow is
coming off there heading towards the
liver and they will all be recycled now
when these triglycerides are cleaved by
the approaching lipase the mature
chylomicron ends up becoming chylomicron
remnants and it loses its its b48 as
well as its as well as its c2 and all
that's left is the apoE which can bind
the april receptor or the LDL receptor
and be taken up by the liver and when it
is taken up here it's a vehicle he comes
over and binds the the receptor here the
apoE receptor or the or the LDL receptor
and it's endocytosed here so this is
endocytosis and once it's taken up by
the liver lysosomes will then fuse with
it and basically break it up into all
its different components and so we'll
have fatty fatty acids cholesterol amino
acids clothes for all these different
things to be recycled by the liver so
that's kind of what chylomicrons do they
take these these dietary lipids that we
started with up here on the top left
start it off with these
we take them in and we send them through
our blood to the tissues that need them
and then take whatever is left over and
recycle it hope that video was helpful
thank you for watching thanks for
watching be sure to LIKE comment
subscribe and don't forget to share the
video of anyone who you think might find
it helpful thanks and happy studying